[Musique]
j'ai 38 ans
je m'appelle Eva Ménard
et il y a aujourd'hui
deux cœurs qui battent en moi
il m'a fallu pas mal d'années pour en
arriver là
vouloir un enfant
pour beaucoup de raisons
l'une d'entre elles se cache dans une
épreuve qui a commencé à l'adolescence
j'ai alors 14 ans
quelque chose de très étrange se produit
je suis dans ma chambre en train
d'écrire
et au même moment je me retrouve sur un
banc face à la mer
et au même moment
dans la cuisine de mon enfance où je
suis une petite fille
des tâches roses apparaissent dans les
airs
et je me vois en dehors de mon propre
corps
à ce moment-là je suis incapable de me
rappeler comment je m'appelle
ni où je suis
après un long moment de panique
je reviens à moi et je pense
ma fille tu es complètement folle faut
surtout pas que ça sache
je ne dis rien à personne
et j'implore ma tête d'avoir la décence
de ne jamais refaire ça
quatre ans plus tard le même accident
et trois ans plus tard puis deux puis un
puis tous les mois et bientôt chaque
semaine
j'ai 24 ans
à ce moment là ma vie d'artiste est déjà
bien avancée je suis compositrice auteur
et interprète
j'ai un groupe de musique avec mon
amoureux avec lequel on tourne beaucoup
en France à l'étranger les petites mises
en chênes on répète on compose en tout
le temps et une idée sournoise s'insinue
dans mon esprit
et si
un accident m'arrivait sur scène
cet été là je dirige une gigantesque
chorale dans un spectacle de deux heures
je suis sous les feux des projecteurs et
je me demande vais-je perdre la boule là
maintenant tout de suite
comment vais-je faire pour diriger la
centaine de chanteurs en face de moi si
je suis en même temps là et dans ma
salle de bain sans plus comprendre la
musique
quand un accident m'arrive si je me
regarde dans le miroir
je suis incapable de savoir qui est la
personne en face imaginez
votre identité vous évolue
et par vous même en plus
vos liens vos souvenirs avec les gens
disparaissent
alors vous avez terriblement honte de
vous-même et vous préférez continuer à
le cacher
si je ne parle pas et que je m'isole
pendant la crise de panique qui suit
personne ne peut savoir ce qui m'arrive
un jour un accident m'arrive avec mon
amour
et là il voit immédiatement qu'il y a un
problème
longuement après être revenu à moi je me
lance je peux plus le cacher
et je commence à lui raconter à lui à ma
sœur
je trouve difficilement les mots pour
leur dire ce qui se passe
je suis là et dans un milliard
d'endroits en même temps
[Musique]
je vois j'entends des choses qui
n'existent pas
comme tout ça se passe dans ma tête
je décide d'aller consulter un psy
je ne pense malheureusement pas être
tombé sur le couteau le plus aiguisé du
tiroir
puisqu'à peine a-t-il entendu deux
minutes de mon histoire qu'il sait déjà
il va régler tout ça avec une bonne
grosse psychanalyse sur mon enfance
j'aimais casseroles comme tout le monde
mais je pressens là comme un décalage
entre le remède sugéré et le problème
auquel je fais face
j'ai 26 ans
l'explication à venir d'une source
inattendue
mon dos est complètement bloqué je veux
voir mon ostéopathe
et à la fin de la science comme
d'habitude elle manipule mon crâne et là
elle remarque quelque chose de très
bizarre il bouge plus du tout
elle me demande si c'est passé quelque
chose
la veille j'ai eu un de ses accidents
et là je fonds en larmes en slip sur sa
table
je pleure toutes ces années à le cacher
le plus fort possible et à me convaincre
que ce n'est rien
elle recueille simplement et avec
bienveillance ma peine et elle me glisse
le numéro d'un neurologue
je suis épileptique
il m'a fallu plus de 10 ans pour
découvrir le diagnostic
une errance en grande partie liée à mon
silence
c'est une des leçons qui me reste
derrière de cette période
peu importe l'obstacle que vous
traversez ne restez pas seul avec
il y a tellement de gens qui vivent la
même chose que vous
qui peuvent vous aider et que vous
pourrez aider
l'épilepsie c'est un dérèglement de
l'activité électrique du cerveau comme
un orage qui court-circuit de votre
intérieur et ça peut mettre un peu de
temps avant que le courant ne revienne
correctement moi typiquement l'image que
j'en avais avant d'être concernée c'est
l'enfant qui s'effon dans une salle de
classe et qui convulse mais j'ai
découvert que cette maladie revêt des
formes incroyablement variées
chez moi ce sont majoritairement des
crises partielles des tas de zones
s'allument dans mon cerveau mais pas
toutes c'est pour ça que je suis encore
consciente
je peux être dans le passé un
espace-temps qui fait aucun sens
et être encore avec vous
dans ma tête si vous voulez c'est un
petit peu comme à Saint-Pal de Noël qui
s'allume mais version moi joyeuses fêtes
que film d'horreur
quand je reçois le diagnostic
je suis soulagée
je ne suis pas folle
je me souviens avoir cru que c'était une
ligne d'arrivée
hasard de la vie alors qu'on cherche un
label avec notre groupe de musique un
label indépendant une très grosse maison
de disque qui nous propose de nous
signer chez elle
le diagnostic la signature
deux étapes qui ressemblent beaucoup aux
franchissement d'un CAP
j'ai dit ressemble seulement pourquoi
avec l'arrivée du diagnostic je vais
découvrir un merveilleux chant
d'interdit
il faut arrêter de travailler la nuit
arrêter le stress arrêtez les voyages
qui fatiguent donc les tournées arrêtez
de conduire ne pas faire de boxe
j'adore la belote en solo à la maison
je commence également à un traitement
médicamenteux qui remplit ses promesses
à 200%
sur les effets secondaires
mais 0 sur la fréquence des crises
je deviens apathique de hors modestement
14 heures par nuit fait une ou deux
siestes par jour une ou deux crises par
jour et j'ai la Vivacity d'esprit d'une
dinde amputée d'un seul de ces deux
neurones
la seule partie sympathique du
traitement c'est ma désinhibition
nouvelle qui mène à deux cocasses
échanges avec de sombres inconnues je
pense par exemple à ce moment où on
essaie de jouer dans un des plus gros
festivals de découverte d'Europe un
concert par hasard je vois le directeur
au loin que je n'avais jamais vu
auparavant ou auparavant et la seule
chose que je pense à faire c'est du
force dessus je claque la bise et je lui
fais une blague incroyablement pourrie
sur ce nom de famille
bon on n'a pas été programmé
comme les médocs qui ne tiennent pas
leurs promesses
notre parcours en maison disque est
intéressante mais nous contraint les
stratégies dans le processus de création
qui ne nous ressemble pas
pondre absolument des singles pour
passer en radio alors qu'on fait de la
musique il dit depuis nos débuts nous
fallait fait de vouloir faire rentrer un
rond turbulent dans un tout petit carré
je fais des crises presque tous les
jours je suis pharmacien le protocole ne
fonctionne pas
je ne sais pas vivre autrement qu'en
enchaîne dans les nuits blanches
l'intensité émotionnelle ou le stress
des premières
avec les crises ma mémoire ressens plus
à celle de Tata Germaine qui a une jeune
femme dans la force de l'âge
des souvenirs qui ne me disent rien
alors que certes la photo atteste que je
suis présente j'en suis déjà là
j'ai 27 ans
et je me pose alors quatre questions
est-il réaliste de penser que je peux
poursuivre ma carrière artistique avec
des crises quasi journalières
de
jusqu'où ma mémoire va-t-elle continuer
à décliner
vais-je devenir une charge pour mon
entourage
et 4 dans ces conditions comment
pourrais-je un jour seulement imaginer
vouloir fonder une famille
je me souviens d'un moment précis
je suis en train de conduire j'avais
théoriquement pas le droit mais mon
assureur n'en saura jamais rien n'est-ce
pas
je m'arrête au bord d'un champ je
descends ma soie sur l'herbe
je pense être quelqu'un d'assez joyeux
mais pour la première et unique fois de
ma vie je pense
j'ai plus envie de vivre
pas comme ça
et c'est là que tout a changé
parce que oui
je veux vivre
alors dans le creux de la vague
je commence à m'approprier cette maladie
à comprendre que personne ne fait les
mêmes crises pour les mêmes raisons
personne ne réagit pas au traitement
je parle à mon neurologue décide
d'arrêter les médicaments et je commence
à me pencher sur des solutions
alternatives pour essayer de réduire les
crises
j'essaye de comprendre empiriquement ce
qu'il est déclenche et comme pour
beaucoup de personnes épileptiques assez
vite le manque de sommeil devient une
évidence
après une décennie a travaillé jusqu'à 5
du mat j'entre voilà un petit challenge
mais il me revient à l'esprit contre ma
couleur de cheveux et les crises il y a
quelques centaines d'années j'aurais été
bonne pour le bûcher
alors je relativise
et je commence par le sport
je me mets à courir en forêt
et l'amélioration de mes nuits est assez
vite impressionnante j'ajoute alors
d'autres sports beaucoup de sport la
natation du fitness du yoga dupital du
Pilate la rando de la du cardio du
badminton
je me force à travailler plus le jour et
moi la nuit
et j'atteins une crise sous les deux
mois
à ce moment où je comprends qu'il faut
se libérer de la voix des autres pour
pouvoir penser et agir librement
la même chose se passe dans notre sphère
professionnelle
on fait une contre-proposition à notre
maison disque ce qui ne se fait pas trop
à l'époque
récupérer l'enveloppe budgétaire
destinée à être dépensé dans un gros
studio branché de la capitale pour créer
notre propre studio d'enregistrement et
enregistrer l'album et ainsi
s'autonomiser pour les années à venir
avec notre outil de travail
un nouveau réflexe n'est dans mon esprit
celui de s'autoriser à créer un chemin
que l'on n'a jamais vu
je commence aussi l'autohypnose pour
pouvoir conditionner position mes nuits
puis la méditation
et je découvre le chant du développement
personnel
je me dis également que les problèmes de
mémoire d'une très vieille personne
peuvent ne pas être une fatalité et je
trouve des exercices pour l'entraîner
exactement comme avec le sport je me
lave les dents avec la main gauche le
conditionne pour retenir les prénoms des
gens et je trouve des compléments
alimentaires pour pour favoriser la
régénération neuronale et devinez quoi
ça marche
je réalise alors que tous ces
ingrédients
stabilisent non seulement mon épilepsie
mais il change il bouleverse
profondément ma vie
ils améliorent profondément l'image de
moi ma conscience ma qualité de travail
et de relations aux autres
c'est comme si
l'épilepsie m'avait appris à mieux vivre
finalement
la question est
l'orage fait sans elle
en parallèle on quitte définitivement
notre maison de disque pour fonder notre
propre maison d'artiste
un collectif dont l'objectif est la
création transdisciplinaire on a bat les
barrières entre cinéma musique théâtre
arts visuels et autres et on se
rassemble entre artistes et personne est
acteur dans cet état d'esprit de partage
de savoir-faire connaissance et outils
de travail
j'ai 33 ans
et je m'apprête à fêter mes 1 an sans
crise
arrêtez vous allez me faire pleurer
un ancien crise depuis plus de 15 ans
j'enchaîne quelques nuits blanches pour
une nouvelle création
je fais une crise très grosse
et là je suis déçu de moi-même
en voyant ma réaction je comprends qu'il
me reste une dernière étape à franchir
accepter ma maladie pleinement
c'est le moment pour moi d'en parler pas
seulement à mes proches
prendre une parole publique sur le sujet
en tant qu'artiste afin de transcender
ma blessure
je compose un morceau qui s'appelle
orage et qui raconte ce qui se passe
dans ma tête durant une crise
j'explique ce qui est le plus difficile
pour moi vers le lien avec les gens que
j'aime
j'écris et je coralise le clip qui
l'accompagne et décide de les sortir le
8 février 2021 à l'occasion de la
Journée internationale de l'épilepsie
voilà tout est dit jamais je n'aurais pu
imaginer les conséquences
j'ai reçu des centaines de messages de
plein de pays de personnes épileptiques
ou d'autres qui vont découvrir le
diagnostic en se reconnaissant dans les
symptômes dont je parle les familles
désemparés ou des gens qui comme moi
auparavant ont de même et se cachent
l'association épilepsie France me
demande de devenir leur marraine pour
mon plus grand honneur
je découvre des femmes et des hommes qui
dédient leur vie à l'amélioration de mes
semblables d'une façon incroyable je me
retrouve à parler publiquement de cette
maladie à écrire la phosphate d'un
ouvrage sur le sujet et le clip report
des prix dans les festivals du film
internationaux
cette envie de transmettre
elle se déploie bien sûr dans mon monde
artistique avec le collectif on intègre
de jeunes artistes avec qui l'on partage
nos outils de développement de carrière
et cette conscience du pouvoir de la
collaboration
on fait également grandir nos ambitions
avec une activité cinématographique
croissante je m'en barre pleinement du
métier de scénariste et réalisatrice
comme un symbole après avoir raconté mon
histoire en musique raconter d'autres
histoires en images viennent s'ajouter
aux battement de ma création
aujourd'hui j'ai 38 ans
et la Eva de 38 ans a envie de dire à
l'ado terrifiée de 14 piges n'est pas
honte de toi
cette épreuve
c'est une aventure qui va te faire
grandir te nourrir humainement et
artistiquement elle va te donner un
équilibre fantastique
depuis lors bien sûr la vie a jeté
d'autres embûches sur ma route
mais l'épilepsie m'a fait le cadeau de
m'apprendre énormément de choses dans ce
site
accepte ce que tu ne peux changer lâche
prise ou tu ne peux rien
et agissent sur ce sur quoi tu peux agir
trouve un chemin peu importe le projet
trouve un chemin personnel unique
extravagance du hasard
le jour où l'on m'a proposé de parler
devant vous
c'est le jour où j'ai appris que j'étais
enceinte
comme une touchant de coïncidence en
direction de la transmission
comme un appel à vous raconter ce chemin
et en embrasser un nouveau
je sais déjà que lorsque je serai mère
s'il m'arrive une crise
je ne serai pas capable de reconnaître
mon propre enfant
mais je n'ai plus peur de ça
l'orage peut venir oui maintenant je le
sais toujours l'orage va passer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore une fois dans un champion
l'orage gagne tous mes souverains
la nuit
s'étire sur
ramène-moi si je ramène moi quand je
ramène moi quand je quitte
ramène moi quand je glisse
le mé
[Musique]
chant à moi
si je mets ça
va moi
mes yeux
dérivent l'enfer devient désir
je
veux fort me sauve
que tu es pour moi chaque je suis pour
toi comment tu ris pour moi comment je
fais
[Musique]
chaque je suis pour toi comme un jour
pour toi
[Musique]